the Battle of Winterfell which took
place during season 8 episode 3 the long
night was the most epic battle on Game
of Thrones yet the production was to say
the least a brutal labor of love here
are just a few of the most amazing
things about it and how they were
brought to life warning spoilers ahead
over the course of 11 weeks a cast and
crew of 750 people worked in the worst
imaginable weather conditions battling
freezing temperatures and all the
elements to make history
director Miguel sapota Nick who has
directed some of the most legendary
Thrones episodes to date took the helm
here in order to keep off the undead
army a giant moat was created around
Winterfell the whites famously do not
like fire so to keep them away
Melisandre lights it all on fire yes the
fire you saw was real in order to
achieve this effect they used about 900
steel logs they chose steel instead of
wood as they would appear to catch fire
without completely burning away to make
the fire spread in the first place they
filled water troughs with gallons and
gallons of propane the fire was
important to add light to a battle that
was mostly shot in the dark of night a
fact that has been controversial for
Game of Thrones fans as it made it hard
to know what was happening at times
cinematographer Fabian Wagner told Wired
the showrunners decided that this had to
be a dark episode and everything they
wanted the audience to see is there a
lot of dead bodies pile up in this
episode and the crew used practical
effects whenever they could
many of the whites that pop up in the
crypt were heavily inspired by the look
of ancient mummies - Kang's skin and all
the whites were mostly a combination of
prosthetics and CGI prop dead bodies
meanwhile are not easy to handle they're
expensive heavy and hard to move around
the prop makers came up with a trick
following the Battle of the bastards
instead of having to stick individual
bodies up
they would stack up a mound of dummies
and create a detailed mold of them the
team created around 300 of these body
piles this episode wasn't going to end
without the death of a fan-favorite and
the long night gave us the demise of
Lyanna Mormont played by Bella Ramsey
who sacrifices herself to kill off the
giant white achieving this involved
complicated and groundbreaking CGI they
shot a piece of the scene on location in
order to get the backdrop while on set a
crew member held a giant head on a tall
pole while this was happening the camera
operators were using in cam this
technology allowed them to playback
animation of what the Giants performance
would look like that was then synced to
the camera this allowed the camera
operators to actually see the Giant at
his proper scale while on set then
against a green screen actor Ian white
who's over seven feet tall actually
played the giant he was filmed in a way
that made him seem like he was double
his size
Ramsey wasn't actually on set with him
so for the shots where the giant picks
her up he instead lifted up a green doll
covered in tracking markers that scene
was then motion captured in the final
layer for close-up shots Ramsey was
lifted up by a giant robotic arm that
picked her up and moved her exactly as
the giant would the giant wasn't even
close to the biggest creature involved
in the battle they were the three
dragons
Ragle drogon and Viserion famously
whenever you see shots of John and
Daenerys riding the dragons in reality
they're actually riding on what looks
like a big mechanical bull they also
actually shoot fire on set the rest of
what you see on screen as well as the
color of vissarion's flames is largely a
result of CGI animating Vissarion
breathing fire differed from the two
alive dragons part of that was because
Viserion breathes blue fire but also
this dragon is injured he's leaking as
VFX supervisor Joe Bower points out he
has a hole in his neck
he's missing half his face by the time
John snow comes face to face with him
you can see fire coming out of different
parts of his face the damage caused by
the dragon's fire was added by
production designers they walked around
with flamethrowers and covered rubble
with dirt and mud after 20 minutes of
watching a battle you're over it's a
poached nick said to Entertainment
Weekly so how do you stop it from being
a battle in that sense the biggest
inspiration for this battle was the
Battle of Helm's Deep from the Lord of
the Rings the two towers which sapota
Nick notes is actually three different
intercut battles but that doesn't mean
the action wasn't incredibly important
the star of the episode might have been
Maisie Williams who's Arya Stark
delivers the fatal blow to the night
king that saves Winterfell it was a long
road for Williams leading to this
episode she said the director called her
a gear before the long night start
shooting and told her to start training
but she had no idea what exactly she was
training for to prepare for some of the
sets tight spaces weapons master Tommy
Dunn gave Arya staff that would
disassemble allowing her to fight in
narrow spaces with the exception of some
of the more dangerous moments Williams
does most of her own stunts
in fact she's so committed to Arya that
the right-handed Williams learned how to
fight left-handed just so she could
fight the same way Arya did in the books
when she took down the night king she
was attached to a wire and launched into
him that sequence was mostly shot in
front of a green screen so the crew
could have better control over the
environment